Lucian's engineer at our studio today
we're going to talk about how the new
our studio one that one terminal feature
can help for our users who submit our
code to HPC and grids so for a bit of
background one of the ways that you can
scale R is by running our in parallel
across a grid computing environment
typically these environments have a
central resource manager like torque PBS
or LSF that handles the submission and
management of jobs and the typical
workflow for an R user is to develop our
code in our studio on their local
machine and then submit that our code to
the grid where it's run in parallel via
and typically a package like batch tools
or just a shell script that makes
requests to the the job management
platform again that would be something
like LSF PBS or torque so that's the the
standard setup and today we're going to
look at how the new terminal feature in
our studio 1.1 can make your life as an
analyst and are much easier when you're
using these types of HPC grids I'm going
to switch over to our studio this is our
studio version 1.1 you can see in
addition to the things I'll be showing
you today the new version 1.1 also has a
great dark theme that's that we're using
so I'm inside of a pretty simple project
in our studio and what I want to do is
take some code in this case it'll be a
hollow world example so really simple
code let me blow it up so everyone can
see and submit this code to run against
a cluster I'm using PBS in torque as my
job submission tool so the way that
you're able to do this easily today and
version 1.1 of our studio is with the
new terminal tab the terminal tab allows
you to open and close terminals on the
local machine
so I'll go ahead and get started with a
new terminal and this terminal gives you
full access to the the machine that is
currently running our studio so I can do
kind all kinds of things that I would
normally do in a terminal for instance I
can list the files in this project this
ternal tab though can make your life a
lot easier if you're trying to submit
jobs to an interactive cluster and we'll
look at a few tricks for doing that
today so the first thing that I'm going
to do after I've developed my code that
I want to run against a cluster is
interactively run that code once on one
edge node of my cluster and the way that
I'm going to do that specifically with
PBS and torque is I'm going to request
an interactive job the way I do that is
in the terminal I can run the command Q
sub - I and this asks the job scheduler
to give me an interactive terminal on
one of the nodes in the HPC cluster so
when I hit enter you can see there's two
things that are printed out the first is
this waiting for job 3 command this
tells me that PBS has received my
request and then the second line here
says job 3 is ready and that means that
the interactive terminal on that HPC
node is now ready and that's actually
where I am this terminal looks the same
but in fact I'm actually running now
instead of on the our studio machine in
one of the nodes of this PBS cluster so
to go back to our architecture diagram
I'm still inside of our studio on my
local machine but the terminal is now
pointed and running in a session on one
of the HPC nodes and this lets me do a
lot of interesting things one of them is
that I can actually run our on this edge
node so I'm going to do that just by
typing R and now I have an R console
inside of the
hpc grid node this can be really handy
because now I can take the script and
run it interactively in the same
environment where it'll ultimately be
executed in parallel and a headless
state so for instance I can put my
cursor here on the first line of the
file and by clicking command option
enter or control option enter on a
Windows machine I can send the our code
directly to this new console inside the
our studio terminal you can see there
were echoing hello PBS I can tell the
console is sleep for 15 seconds and I
can print goodbye so this is a really
useful feature and that I can walk
through my script exactly in the
environment where I will want it to run
and this is really handy for debugging
problems in HPC execution of your code
now one important thing to point out is
that this our console is entirely
separate from our studio and it can be
kind of easy to get confused here
so let's let's take a look inside of our
studio we have this console tab the
console tab is running our on the our
studio machine on this local machine
here and if I create a variable x equals
1 it'll show up inside of the
environment pane and I can see in my
history tab I also have that statement
so all of the features you would expect
in our studio if I switch over to the
terminal I do not have that same
connection between our studio and the
HAR console so I'm able to send code you
know line by line from this our file to
the terminal but that's it so for
example if I create a variable here Y is
1 that's not going to show up inside my
environment pain because I'm running in
this new detached mode inside my HPC
tool so it's not a 100% integration to
something we are working on at our
studio for the release 1.3
which will be in about a year but but it
is definitely a step in the right
direction and it's much easier than if
you've done this job submission worked
before all right so I'm going to go
ahead and quit out of our and I'm gonna
exit my interactive session you can see
when I typed exit there the job three
that I was in completed so now I'm back
in the terminal on the our studio local
machine now that I know my hello world
script runs my next step is to submit it
to the grid to run in parallel and I'm
going to do that using this submit job
shell script this is a simple example of
what a PBS submission script looks like
if you're not familiar with PBS
submission scripts that's okay
most companies that have an HPC system
in place have template files for you to
use but the setup is actually pretty
simple here we're saying that I want to
name this job hello underscore world I
want to submit it to the Q batch and
here we're specifying the resources for
this job
so I want one node and my wall time is
going to be two minutes so so a maximum
amount of time for this script would be
two minutes and then we tell the command
that we want to run in this case our
script hello world our and if that
command runs right we'll exit
successfully with a status code of zero
so a very simple submission script and
the way that we can run this from our
studio again making use of the new
terminal feature in the terminal I'm
going to run Q sub and then I'm just
going to give it the name of this script
when I do that and hit enter it's going
to print out a job ID and I can check on
the status of this job right from within
our studio by saying Q stat for and
it'll tell me some information about
this job if I want even more detailed
information I can say Q stat - f4 and
it'll print out a whole bunch of
information about this job
you can see that the the job was
actually running well I did this and
then if I do this again the job will
actually be done running so we can see
an exit status here of zero and also see
that output was routed directly back
into my home directory so here we have
the output of the hello world and that
standard error of the hello world script
for job four if we open this guy up you
can see what we expect that it says
hello PBS and goodbye so hopefully this
gives you a good sense for have a new
terminal tab can be used to both
interactively run our code inside your
HPC environment for debugging and for
testing as well as how easy it is to
submit jobs using the terminal to your
cluster and check on their status thanks
so much have a good day